I am taking January off and while I'm
gone some amazing creators are gonna be
taking over this channel we start with
Rowan Francis a cardiologist who runs
med life crisis his video includes
footage from his diving trip to Borneo
and a couple of jokes that I am deeply
uncomfortable with Rowan oh dear how
long can you hold your breath 1 2
minutes
I'm sorry Homo sapiens is just pretty
pathetic next to the diving and world
champions who can stay underwater for
one or two hours so how do they do it
well there are a few different ways some
you can actually take advantage of by
channeling your inner dolphin others
involve a little bit of gentle evolution
so maybe a bit of a tall order for most
of us unless you're a member of an Asian
community we've evolved into real-life
Aquaman
[Music]
there are five ways we can spend longer
under water number one is to increase
your tolerance to carbon dioxide the
first thing that makes you want to take
a breath is a rising level of carbon
dioxide or hypercapnia hyper from the
Greek meaning too much or above and
kapnos meaning smoke this acidic waste
gas builds up and the body is so acutely
sensitive to any changes in pH even
though it's tiny that it starts
screaming at you to breathe goddamn you
incidentally this is why any diet
claiming to alkalinize your blood is
basically now you can improve your
carbon dioxide tolerance quite quickly I
was able to go from about 90 seconds
breath-hold to 5 minutes with just a few
days worth of snorkelling and some tips
from an experienced free diver the next
obstacle though is a lot harder to get
around and that's hypoxia or low oxygen
hypoxia kill cells no matter how you die
ultimately its hypoxia at the cellular
level ie your cells being starved of
oxygen that is the cause of your
inevitable death unlike training your
body to become more tolerant to
hypercapnia increasing your tolerance to
hypoxia takes years of training and of
course there is a level past which no
human can actually go so what does
solution for a longer dive well to
maximize oxygen delivery and minimize
oxygen use which brings me to number two
the reason that this steak is red is a
protein called myoglobin which is found
in the muscles of pretty much every
mammal and it's responsible for storing
oxygen however if we were tucking into a
steak that came from a seal it would be
almost black in appearance because
they've got ten times more myoglobin
than humans or cows this is not a human
steak so why can't we just pack it more
myoglobin and store more oxygen like the
seals do the problem with proteins is
the problem with proteins is that when a
very first problem with proteins the
problem with proteins is when they get
too tightly packed they start to clump
together and lose their function but
marine mammals have evolved a very
clever way to deal with this their
variant of the myoglobin molecule has a
positive electric charge as I'm sure you
know positive repels positive and as a
result the proteins can get very close
together without forming those clumps
number three is to adjust your blood
flow to preferentially supply the heart
and the brain at the expense of things
like the extremities which are much more
tolerant to having a reduced blood flow
and number four is to slow your heart
down the heart is a very oxygen hungry
organ so by reducing your heart rate
you're immediately buying yourself more
time under water I've mentioned these
two together because they form part of
the dive reflex erroneously sometimes
called the mammalian dive reflex it's
actually been found in pretty much every
air breathing vertebrate that's been
studied it's stimulated by submersion in
water particularly cold water and
remember below 200 meters depth water is
cold no matter where you are in the
world and of course that's where most
mammals do their hunting so what is the
dive reflex well let's take a look
[Music]
that that's the wrong video I've not
tried this before but I filled up a
basin with ice water and I'm going to
hold my breath and submerge my face in
the water probably just for about 30
seconds or so and I'll see if anything
happens to my heartrate I've got a pulse
oximeter and that you can see okay here
goes
[Music]
that was cold so heart rate has dropped
right down to 45 I'd still stay at 45 I
don't know how long I was under maybe 30
40 seconds and now you could see it
slowly starting to climb again this is
just a cheap 10 pound ox limited that I
bought online so I don't know how low
their heart rate goes at dinner when it
starts becoming inaccurate but a lot of
these commercial devices will have a cut
off in the 40s because most people's
heart rate doesn't go that low but I
think it was a pretty clear
demonstration in diving mammals this is
far more pronounced with Weddell seals
for example dropping the heart rate as
low as four beats a minute this effect
is mediated by my favorite nerve the
vagus don't tell me you don't have a
favorite nerve number five is also part
of the dive reflex because it has
another feature and that's to squeeze
your spleen the spleen is normally a
small organ which is involved with the
immune system and filtering the blood
and as such stores a little reservoir of
blood now in a healthy human with a
normal-sized spleen that volume will be
around 160 milliliters of blood or 5%
extra oxygen carrying ability which can
be squeezed out as part of the dive
reflex when needed
however diving mammals can have
significantly enlarged spleens
representing a much bigger reservoir of
blood to be provided when necessary I'm
sorry it looks like this one's out of
reach for most of us but that doesn't
mean that there aren't any members of
our species that haven't taken advantage
however to meet them we're going to need
to take a short trip to Southeast Asia
years ago I saw a BBC documentary that
stuck in my mind permanently which was
about a fisherman who was so negatively
buoyant he essentially sank 20 meters
and walked along the bottom of the
seabed and what's more he almost
effortlessly held his breath for several
minutes he was a member of the badger
community who are an ethnic group
indigenous to oceanic Southeast Asia the
Philippines Indonesia and here I'm in
North Borneo at the moment in Sabah
where they're one of the biggest ethnic
groups and my diving instructors here
tell legendary stories of badger who can
hold their breath for 15 minutes at a
time underwater so what makes them so
special
the Bajau have led a nomadic subsistence
lifestyle for at least a thousand years
literally living out at sea eating what
they catch and rarely setting foot on
land earlier this year a research team
led out of Copenhagen published an
incredible study which demonstrated that
the Bajau have evolved larger than
average spleens when compared to nearby
non diving communities free divers
developed big spleens through training
but the enlarged spleens of the Bajau
are seen in members of the community who
don't do any fishing or diving so we
know that this is a genetic adaptation
you might wonder how a genetic pressure
has been exerted until you consider the
fact that the Bajau who dive spend five
hours underwater per day so you can
easily imagine how any mutation to
confer an increased diving ability would
have been positively selected they
identified many genetic variations seen
in the Badger but to snappily titled
genes stood out P de 10 a is a gene
noted to have differences amongst the
Bajau specifically the part of the gene
that is responsible for thyroid function
and spleen size and the BDK rb2 gene is
involved in the blood redistribution
part of the dive reflex that we talked
about earlier rather like the Sherpa in
the high altitude Himalaya this is
evidence of human evolution from our
fairly recent past and now we're in the
era of genetic analysis becoming
commonplace we were able to trace
specific mutations and how they've
travelled through time and
geographically to make us the people we
are today
but does research like this actually
benefit patients here in hospital well I
see the effects of hypoxia secondary to
disease on a daily basis where it causes
death and disability the hope is that by
understanding how that Vijaya or the
Sherpa have adapted to life in a low
oxygen environment might guide
development of new treatments to help
their critically ill honey over I've
thought of a name just just hear me out
here what do you think of Tom Scott
Francis all right thanks Ron go
subscribe to midlife crisis I would
recommend starting with his minute
medicine video on why you shouldn't run
every medical test even if you can next
week a maths puzzle for you
you